Speaker 1: The other thing that I want
to talk about is actually some good news,
and that is Donald Trump's accountability. The
march for consequence for Donald Trump continues.
There is news that the former publisher of the
National Enquirer, I believe his name is David
Pecker, is now speaking to the grand jury in
Manhattan that has been impaneled surrounding
the hush money payments made to Stormy Daniels.
I'm a real little bit from this New York Times
article entitled Manhattan Prosecutors Begin
Presenting Trump Case to Grand Jury. The Manhattan
District Attorney's decision represents
a dramatic escalation of the inquiry and
potentially sets the case on a path forward toward
criminal charges against the former president.
This is what we need. We need fewer business
cases that result in $1.61 million fines
for an extensive young man who claims to be a
billionaire. Even if he's not, he's worth hundreds
of millions of dollars. A single one and a half
million dollar fine isn't going to be much of a
bump in the road for Donald Trump. It's certainly
not going to dissuade him or deter him from his
criminal activity. But this might when there's
actual criminality and jail time on the line.
The Manhattan District attorney's office on Monday
began presenting evidence to a grand jury about
Donald J. Trump's role in paying hush money to a
porn star during his 2016 presidential campaign,
laying the groundwork for potential criminal
charges against the former president in the coming
months. According to people with knowledge of the
matter, the grand jury was recently impaneled,
and the beginning of witness testimony represents
a clear signal that the district attorney, Alvin
L. Bragg, is nearing a decision about whether to
charge Mr. Trump. On Monday, one of the witnesses
was seen with his lawyer entering the building
in Lower Manhattan, where the grand jury is
sitting. The witness, David Pecker, is the former
publisher of the National Enquirer, the tabloid
that helped broker the deal with the porn star
Stormy Daniels. Now, if you remember this case,
you will know that the will there's a there's a
term called I believe it's catch and kill, where
a journalist outlet like this will offer money to
buy the rights to the story and then do nothing
with it. But they the person they work with,
Stormy Daniels in this case would sign an NDA,
not allowing them to ever tell the story again
because the rights to that story were owned by
the by the newspaper. I'm using that very loosely
here with the National Enquirer. And that seems to
be something along the lines of what was dealt
with here with Donald Trump and Michael Cohen,
who, by the way, pled guilty, pleaded guilty to
these charges. There was criminality here That
has been proven. There have been convictions
related to this, but just not Donald Trump.
As prosecutors prepare to reconstruct the
events surrounding the payment for grand jurors,
they have sought to interview several witnesses,
including the tabloids, former editor Dylan Howard
and two employees at Mr. Trump's company. The
people said Mr. Howard and the Trump Organization
employees Jeffrey Mcconney and Deborah Tassler
off, have not yet testified before the grand
jury. The prosecutors have also begun contacting
officials for Mr. Trump's 2016 campaign. One
of the people said, and in a sign that they
want to corroborate these witness accounts,
the prosecutors recently subpoenaed phone records
and other documents that might shed light on the
episode. A conviction is not a sure thing, in
part because a case could hinge on showing that
Mr. Trump and his company falsified records to
hide the payout from voters days before the 2016
election, a low level felony charge that would be
based on largely untested legal theory. The case
would also rely on the testimony of Michael Cohen,
Mr. Trump's former fixer who made the payment,
and who himself pleaded guilty to federal charges
related to the hush money in 2018. So, listen, I
don't understand the trepidation from The New York
Times reporting here, because we have a guilty.
We have a conviction in the case related.
You think Michael Cohen was making hush money
payments for Donald Trump out of the goodness
of his own heart, out of his own pocket?
Come on. This is something to follow.
Donald Trump is in dire need of a legal
consequence for his actions, in dire need of
consequence for his crimes, whether it be this,
whether it be obstruction of justice, whether it
be inciting an insurrection against the United
States of America. But it has to start somewhere.
And I'm glad that Alvin Bragg is back on the case
after kind of shying away from the initial
charges. I'm glad that this is before a grand
jury. That is where it starts. And hopefully
that's where we're going to get some traction.
Once again, my name is Jesse Dallimore. You can
subscribe to me on YouTube. Just search Jesse
Dallimore Dallimore daily. You can also follow me
on Instagram, on Twitter, on Tik Tok, all across
the social media. Just search at dallimore. And
of course, you can subscribe to my podcast, my
twice weekly podcast co-hosted by the lovely and
talented Brittney Page. It's called I Doubt It.